[Music]
prove you're smiling I like that
let's take a look at your response did
you come up with the right one no what
is we love you out that's very kind
thank you
Alex Trebek has hosted hundreds of
episodes of Jeopardy but he's never had
a final answer like this one before I'm
a lucky guy I'm really lucky the game
show host announced in March that he had
been diagnosed with stage 4 pancreatic
cancer this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this and
I'm gonna keep working and with the love
and support of my family and friends and
with the help of York prayers also
despite his diagnosis he's continued to
host the show in between his
chemotherapy treatments I plan to beat
the low survival rate statistics for
this disease truth told I have to
because under the terms of my contract I
have to host jeopardy for three more
years so help me keep the faith and
we'll win we'll get it done
well on monday's episode of Jeopardy
Tournament of Champions he got the
sweetest message of support from one of
the contestants and you might want to
grab a box of tissues did you come up
with the right one
no what is we love you out that's very
kind thank you
it all went down during the show's final
Jeopardy segment when instead of writing
in an actual question a contestant wrote
we love you Alex
he wagered all but five dollars so he
essentially threw away his shot at
winning in order to extend a little love
to the TV legend Kostya 1995 you're left
with 5 bucks ok naturally the sweet
gesture made its rounds on social media
and the hashtag we love you Alex was
born the contestant also took to Twitter
after the episode aired to share the
story behind the tear filled moment
quote I'm really glad I got the
opportunity to say to Alex what
everybody at the tournament was thinking
he explained that Alex had just told
them that he was re-entering treatment
for his cancer adding when Final
Jeopardy came up I could have tried to
puzzle it together but really just kept
thinking about Alex and thought he
should know in terms of getting my
strength back that hasn't happened
unfortunately you said you having to go
through another round of chemo yeah was
that the plan always or no Alex sat down
with Good Morning America in September
to talk about his announcement that he
had to undergo another round of
chemotherapy due to a setback in
recovery but he made it clear that he
still had high hopes as long as I can
walk out and greet the audience and the
contestants and run the game I'm happy
how are you feeling how's everything
going little tired no time the fans
support has through our office people on
social media everyone in the audience
tonight was on their feet clapping and
cheering what does all that support mean
to you it's blowing me away I told
somebody the other day that most of us
in our lifetimes never get to know the
impact we've had on other people you
only hear about it after the person
passes away and to be able to experience
it while you're alive
is very special and
people have been so kind in all walks of
life sending cards letters offering
advice their prayers
it just it touches me at a very deep
level and it's it's an experience that
on one on one hand I didn't want to
experience and on the other hand I'm
glad it has happened to me because it
has taught me something about where I
stand in the lives of people in America
and where I stand in my own life it's
forced me to re-examine my situation
what do you want your legacy to be how
do you want us to remember you just as a
good guy a nice man and somebody that
you looked at on television on a daily
basis and said hey you know what I like
him
alex is such a class act and so strong
and we are definitely sending him all of
our love of course he can count on et to
bring you all the sweet stories out of
Hollywood like this one so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]